well it seems this is my last broadcast
folks I have made a terrible mistake and
there's no turning back from it
yesterday in a moment of reckless
overconfidence I did something that I
just I can't I can't undo I'm afraid I
was after reading that story about the
Democrats trying to pass a bill to force
boys into girls sports which we'll talk
more about in a few moments yeah I read
that story then and then I sent out a
tweet this is a tweet I sent out I said
this is the challenge I open up to every
liberal please provide one logical
reason to allow biological males into
women's sports if you can provide one
logical reason I will donate all of my
money to an LGBT group and leave the
internet forever just one is all I need
now my point here I was trying to
communicate is that it's such an
illogical thing and I am so confident
that you couldn't possibly come up with
one good reason that I would donate all
of my money and and and go into the
woods in seclusion for the rest of my
days if you could simply come up with
one reason and many people tried to come
up with reasons and none were successful
until the dastardly Jake came along a
guy named Jake came and he said well
I've got a reason if you allow
biological males into women's sports it
would make the WNBA watchable and I read
that and I thought well crap that is a
pretty logical reason to come to think
of it it would make the WNBA watchable
WMAs WNBA in its current form is
completely unwatchable but if you yeah
if you included some men in there I do
think that can you imagine LeBron James
essentially playing five on one against
five women on a WNBA court that would
certainly be highly entertaining in fact
it would probably be more entertaining
than what you get in even the NBA right
now so so there it is I I guess I guess
I lose I tried to explain to my wife
this morning why we're gonna be donating
our life savings to GLAAD and going to
live in the woods forever
and honestly she wasn't very receptive
to the idea it kind of surprised me and
it was pretty frustrating you know I
don't know what she's making a huge deal
about it but I'm a man of my word ladies
and gentleman and and all we can do then
in these final moments together is just
you know try to enjoy it and remember
the good times now a lot to talk about
today in my last broadcast but first a
word from the National Highway Traffic
Safety Administration National Highway
Traffic Safety Administration is working
hard to combat texting while driving
ok cops are writing tickets for people
who text while driving so you drive you
text you pay thousands of people die
every year in crashes related to
distracted driving it's a huge problem
and that's why cops are out there the
right in tickets and it's it's not just
a dangerous problem it's also deadly
between 2012 and 2017 nearly 20,000
people died in crashes related to
distracted driving that's how much of a
of an epidemic this is and if your own
safety isn't enough reason to stop
texting while driving then well how
about this it's illegal and how about
this you know when you when you send or
receive a text and you take your eyes
off the road for about five seconds at
55 miles an hour that's like driving
more than the length of a football field
without looking with your eyes closed so
that's why cops are writing tickets for
this and remember if you text while
driving you will get caught you drive
your texts you pay alright come to think
of it I did open that challenge to
liberals right specifically I did say
liberals I said I opened this challenge
to liberals and and there's no way that
Jake is a liberal if he's making a
comment like that about the WNBA no
self-respecting liberal would ever make
a would ever make a disparaging remark
about the WNBA so I think I get off on a
technicality actually praise God
I so you're not gonna get rid of me that
easy I suppose that was a that was a
close one but all of that stems from
this move by the Democrats that I
mentioned as The Daily wire reported
yesterday every single Democrat in the
house save for just one has voted for a
bill that would force schools to allow
biological males to intrude into
female sports sports and the bill would
amend the Civil Rights Act of 1964 to
offer these legal protections to or Ford
quote gender identity which would compel
schools to make room for biological
males on on girls sports team
now obviously the measure has no hope of
becoming law right now with Trump in the
White House and Republicans controlling
the Senate so it's it's not going to
become law but if and when it ever does
become law if Democrats are running
everything well it would be the end of
women's sports as we know it there's
just no way that women's sports can
survive when you've got when men are
allowed to come in and dominate which of
course they will and that is bad news
for women this is all bad news for
society on a number of levels it's bad
news for common sense and science and
and all of that but politically speaking
this kind of stuff is great news for
Republicans okay the the Democrats here
are rallying around a position that no
sane person in the country thinks is
reasonable not just none okay even these
Democrats themselves don't think it's
reasonable which is why none of them
were talking about this ten years ago
this wasn't an issue that anyone was
talking about but the political winds
have blown them all the way out here
onto the onto the fringes into this sort
of ideological backwater where now the
Democrats feel like they have to appease
the most radical elements of their base
and they feel that in doing that they
have to deny the basic biological
difference of differences between men
and women and aside from them and like I
said those fringe radical elements of
the progressive base no one else is on
board with this so this is a total loser
issue for Democrats it's it's a complete
loser for them the daily wire report
quotes the human rights coalition
statement on this bill now the human
rights coalition they are part of that
fringe ideological radical backwater and
they said that opponents of equality in
athletics for trans
general eats have argued that now of
course the irony is that they are the
ones opposing equality in athletics now
when you've when you've got girls
competing against girls now you've got
essentially equality or some semblance
of equality in athletics because all
because they're all girls
they've all got that in common and then
it just comes down to well who's you
know who's actually the best athlete
within those parameters and you know
who's best prepared and whose practice
the most and that's how you succeed so
that's equality what they're talking
about here is completely unequal when
you put a when you put a man on to the
onto the track against the women runners
that's not equality that's the exact
opposite of it that is a unfair
insurmountable biological inequality but
anyway they said opponents of equality
and athletics of transgender athletes
have have argued that girls who are
transgender have unfair physiological
advantages over cisgender girls and as a
result will dominate women's competitive
sports but they say that this is not
rooted in fact not rooted in fact it is
absolutely a fact that men have more
muscle mass larger fast-twitch muscle
fibers larger lungs larger hearts longer
legs much more testosterone much less
estrogen a larger capacity to produce
oxygen when they exert themselves among
literally dozens of other biological
advantages right and this is as much a
fact as gravity all but the most fringe
and bizarre members of the far left know
and acknowledge this reality now I think
part of what's happening here is that
Democrats are allowing themselves to be
led astray by polling data there is you
know I've looked up the surveys on this
how many Americans really are in favor
of having biological males compete
against girls in high school sports or
sports at any level and I found a couple
of said one survey that I found
says alleges that opinion is basically
evenly split but I am absolutely certain
that these polls which Democrats are
probably looking at do not reflect
public opinion accurately probably
because most people are confused by
references to transgender girls now if
you go to the average person and say
should transgender girls be allowed to
race against other girls and that's
probably the way these poll questions
are phrased I think most people are
gonna say yeah because they most people
don't know what do you mean by that
transgender
most people don't know what that means
they're not familiar with this bizarre
lingo they don't understand that when
you say transgender girl what you mean
is biological male pretending that he's
a girl now if you put it like that if
you say should biological males be
allowed be it be allowed in women's
sports I think you're gonna find that
the the numbers are far more slanted I
mentioned a few weeks ago I did a
completely unscientific the Twitter poll
about this or I asked people should
biological males be allowed into women's
sports that is a fair non biased way of
phrasing it because that's what we're
talking about right and there were
something like thirty five thousand
votes counted and it was ninety-seven
percent against now again not scientific
you know skewed data because most of my
Twitter followers are probably gonna
skew towards being conservative but
still I mean even so I I guarantee you I
could not find that kind of consensus um
with with that bigger group of people on
any other issue I mean I could have put
a pull up about abortion about about
anything gun rights immigration you're
not gonna find a 97 to 3 split even
among conservatives on any other issue
but on this I mean it's just it's just
obvious
so if Democrats want to go this route
they're they're welcome to it
Republicans should beat them over the
head at every opportunity with this
issue the Democrats are
are staking out a position that is
explicitly anti-science anti-woman
and that is a fact that Republicans
would do very well to highlight
frequently and loudly and as we head
into the election season every
Republican who finds himself on a debate
stage with a Democrat should bring up
this issue should force the Democrat to
defend his belief that there are no
biological differences between girls and
boys let the dead let let them you know
let them go out on that limb and try to
explain that I tell you this they don't
want to the the Democrats they don't
want to be asked about this issue
publicly they really don't they what
they want to do is just pander to the
LGBT lobby because they feel like they
have to do that politically and then and
then never have to speak about it again
that's what they want and I think
Republicans ought to not oblige them on
that point now I've always said this is
a winning issue for conservatives and I
think public opinion is shifting more in
our direction on this especially the
more that Democrats push it in fact just
yesterday I happen to cross an article
online from a feminist website from a
website called the feminist current
which is not a website that I usually
check but there was an article called I
supported trans ideology until I
couldn't anymore by a feminist
explaining how she woke up to the
reality that the the that transgenderism
is pseudoscience and it doesn't make any
sense I want to read a quick paragraph
of what she said talking about her days
as a trans advocate and how she used to
advocate for it although she doesn't
anymore
she said when asked when asked why I
believe trans women were in fact women I
asserted that some boys and girls are
born in the wrong body and that our
brains are gendered when asked to
elaborate I pointed to vague notions of
knowing and feeling rather than terms
that were rooted in science and could be
operationalized when asked to explain
further I resorted to circular reasoning
some men feel like women and only women
can feel like women therefore some men
are women when pushed on the question of
how it's possible to feel like a woman
I'd argue that because I felt like a
woman it must be true
other other other times I resorted to
name-calling labeling women who said
trans women were male bigots who were
stuck in the 50s it didn't believe in
civil rights now and then she goes on to
talk about her process of waking up to
reality but this is really fascinating
because when you hear these arguments
about people being born in the wrong
body feeling like men feeling like women
and so on and you wonder how any
rational person could fail to see the
problems with such arguments well this
is how it's someone who feels
politically obligated to say these
things even if they don't understand
what it is they're saying or why they're
saying it all right moving on this is
this is great stuff as reported by the
hill the the City Council in San Jose
California this week voted unanimously
to fly rainbow flags in support of LGBTQ
rights LGBTQ rights near a chick-fil-a
which is going to be open next month
near the city's airport so they got
together and the City Council got
together and voted that they're gonna
troll chick-fil-a by flying rainbow
flags that's I mean it's just so brave
isn't it I am astounded by the bravery
the boldness you know I can really see
why gay rights folks always compare
their plight to the plight of you know
slaves in the 19th century because this
is exactly the same right it's the same
kind of fight same kind of heroism
required on one hand you had the the
Underground Railroad and now you have
rainbow flags the chick-fil-a
drive-through it's just there's no
difference at all right in all
seriousness though it's it's been when
when did this whole thing with
chick-fil-a start it started with with
Dan Kathy with the founder of
chick-fil-a saying in an interview that
he supports biblical marriage and that
was in what 2012 2012 it's been seven
years it's been seven years since the
founder of chick-fil-a said that he
believes in the Bible and the LGBT Lobby
has not given up they have not let up
they can't let it go now in the meantime
chick-fil-a has has not been
discriminating it in fact chick-fil-a it
never at no point ever discriminated
against LGBT people they've always hired
gay people so there's no discrimination
they're not kicking gay people out of
their stores or not denying them
employment so that's never been the case
that's not what what's going on this is
about the founder of chick-fil-a saying
that he believes in the Bible as it
pertains to marriage seven years ago and
they haven't let it go I mean I remember
when this all first happened and it
backfired spectacularly on on the gay
rights people because then you had you
know remember everywhere everyone
started flocking to chick-fil-a and
remember that first day chick-fil-a day
I mean that my local chick-fil-a when I
went to support them they were just
packed to the rafters and it was a huge
backfire and I I thought naive as I am
at the time I figured okay well they're
gonna back off of this and let this go
they had seven years later they still
haven't that's why I say the LGBT Lobby
is just the these are petty vengeful
bullies who will never let anything go
and if you cross them they will not let
you out of their clutches think look
look at what they're doing a jack
Phillips and just keep coming after the
guy I mean he won he essentially won in
the Supreme Court because the the gay
rights folks got got scolded reprimanded
for targeting this guy and he still
won't let him go pettiness and
vengefulness is what you find among the
radical gay left
all right sorry to skip around so much
but I wanted to discuss this for a
moment as well
from CNN says it takes four hands to
open this new condom created by an
Argentine company in a bid to highlight
the importance of consent the consent
pack of condoms was designed by an ad
agency so and so forth it takes four
hands to open it it's just supposed to
help with consent the tagline reads
consent is the most important thing in
sex and the packs unique system requires
four hands or two people to agree to
open it by clicking four buttons on the
top and size of the box at the same time
okay so the consent condom now of course
this is counterproductive and silly for
many reasons starting with the fact that
if your goal is to make sure that people
are using condoms than probably making
it harder to open them is not the way to
go about it and besides according to the
progressive affirmative consent rules
consent has to be verbally and
affirmatively offered throughout the
sexual act that's what they say so just
because you got the box of condoms open
and that doesn't mean anything the terms
as far as as far as consent goes by this
standard but more to the point here's
what I really want to focus on number
one you see yet again just how
complicated everything is when you're
intent on having cheap unattached sex
with strangers if you're intent on that
everything is complicated and you know
now you need special condoms and
everything if you just get married you
don't have to worry about this stuff and
yes I realize that some married people
still use condoms but you don't have to
and you don't need to be terrified that
god forbid the sexual act actually
results in a child which is totally
natural if that were to happen you know
it's not a big deal if you're married
that's not some kind of life shattering
occurrence it's a great blessing even if
you weren't planning on it
even if it's a you know even if you
you're not where you want to be
financially or whatever it's it's it's
it's it's okay because you're married
you've got the you you've got the proper
context to you know in which to
introduce into which you can introduce a
child so just get married and stop
worrying about this it's so much easier
all of these things that single people
people in the dating world especially
those who are determined to continue
being you know sexually active in that
context all these things they worry
about I see that I just think I'm so
glad I don't have to I don't have to
worry about that stuff but the second
point is notice the tagline consent is
the most important thing in sex okay now
it's true that consent obviously is
essential but that's that's a given
because having sex with someone who
doesn't consent is rape that makes you a
rapist and you should go to prison
forever that is if it's actual
non-consensual sex if it's sex where
both people are clearly willing 1/8 and
eager but there is not a verbal and
continuous affirmation all throughout
the act well that just makes you human
because no human does that what we're
not we're not listening how it works
right we're not robots but again if it's
if it's actual non-consensual sex then
it is rape and clearly that's bad that
in fact is one of the worst things a
human can possibly do to another human
but okay let's say that we have the
consent base covered both people want to
do it actively affirmatively verbally
consenting great so that's out of the
way we could put that to the side that's
established okay what's important now
you say is consent is the most important
thing in sex and it's not just this
condom company that says that I mean
this is what this is what you hear from
the left now when it comes to consent is
all that matters
yeah but what what after that what's the
most important thing in consensual sex
you can
say that the most important thing in
consensual sex is consent that that's
you might as well say the most important
thing in sex is sex it's just that's
already that's redundant what's the most
important thing in consensual sex is
there anything else any other concerns
that we should have anything else to
take into account here we've made
consent the only remaining rule the only
remaining ethical standard governing the
sexual act which which is a problem
because there are a lot of other ways
for the sexual act to harm people aside
from rape aside from STDs or unwanted
pregnancies people are harmed by the
sexual act consensual sex all the time
they're harmed emotionally they're
harmed spiritually psychologically
because even though it was consensual if
it wasn't committed if it wasn't loving
if it wasn't respecting of the other
person's dignity then it is harmful to
the person it is degrading and it's
harmful and that is why so often on
college campuses you have people waking
up the next day feeling like they've
been violated even though the sex was
completely consensual they consented
they wanted to do it in the moment later
on they regretted it where is that
coming from you know it's coming from
somewhere it's a very real thing it's
it's a it's a real emotion that you feel
after the fact that you should listen to
now it doesn't mean that you were raped
it doesn't mean that you need to go to
the police because you did consent it
wasn't rape but you were violated you
were violated consensually and you
participated in your own violation but
it was still a violation and that's why
you feel that way
so consent is the most important thing
no actually you see I think love is the
most important thing in sex and love
obviously includes consent
it can't be loving if it isn't willing
but it also includes a lot more than
that primarily it includes I think an
actual concern for the other person as a
person not just as an object of your
sexual fulfillment
so I think we need to introduce that as
well once we've got consent covered how
about dignity respect love commitment
selflessness I mean how about all those
things as well all right this is let's
we'll go to your two emails now Matt
Walsh show at gmail.com Matt Walsh show
at gmail.com go fix mine didn't really
fix it says hi Matt I enjoy your show
and many times I've I've always wanted
to email you with response especially
the ones that make me laugh out loud
your views on marriage kids and overall
human quirkiness is a highlight of my
day
I heard your podcast about the kid
leashes and agree that I used to be anti
kid leash when I wasn't a parent and
then God gave my husband and I five kids
gratulations God does have a sense of
humor and at one time I swore I would
never drive a minivan and feed my kids
junk food but here I am just winging
this parent gig like you stated yeah the
minivan thing is one of the everybody
it's it's just inevitable this is such a
cliche but everyone goes into parenting
saying I'm not gonna get a minivan and
we were the same way and we still don't
have a minivan but last week we were we
ever having some car trouble and I had
one of the cars because I was out
traveling and so we my wife had to head
up ran to a car we have a suburban and
that was in the shops yet we rented a
car go right to the minivan because it's
the biggest thing they had available we
could fit all the kids and of course my
wife drives a minivan around for a week
and she was so anti minivan but she was
great about how great it was having a
minivan
so it just hey you you can't it's gonna
happen eventually you're gonna realize
how great the minivan is and end up
getting one anyway um
sorry I got away from email says I am
more understanding now having kids
myself about the worries parents have of
toddlers who can easily wander off but I
just witnessed something that it was so
weird I had to share this when at the
park the other day I did a double take
when I saw a young couple pushing their
dog in a stroller while their child was
on a leash I am so confused what are
your thoughts on this I know how you
feel about dogs
being dogs not humanizing them which I
totally agree with my first reaction
when I saw this peculiar site was our
society now finds it acceptable to
personify dogs while treating children
more like while treating children more
like love them or leave them pets kids
now seem more like a nuisance which at
one point pets were viewed as now it
just seems like the view is in Reverse
and that's from aundrea I don't know if
I say that yes Andrea I am I am leash
tolerant I am leash accepting as I
stated but if you've got your kid
leashed and your dog in a stroller that
is a bridge too far I mean if you have
to choose between leashing the dog or
leashing the kid I'd say definitely do
the dog in that case there have to be
limits in fact really if I you know I
wouldn't I think the childish as I said
child leashes is I'm I understand it but
I wouldn't even I don't even think I'd
want to leash my kid in the dog at the
same time like if I was taking the dog
for a walk I don't it just the the
optics of that don't don't work for me
really but especially if you only got
one leash to go around you put it on
your kid and not the dog oh man oh man
yeah all right this is from Nick says hi
Matt I'm a huge fan of your show
appreciate all you do as a young
Catholic I have done my best to
familiarize myself with arguments for
the existence of God and I had a
question about the argument of from
slash from causation in college I had a
professor give what I thought was an
interesting reply to the claim that all
of existence has to have a cause what we
call God otherwise there would be an
infinite cause chain of causes and that
is impossible he essentially said that
it is possible to have an infinite chain
of causes with no first cause but we're
not able to logically understand such
comprehend what that means therefore
there does not need to be a first cause
God because an infinite chain of causes
is possible I'm struggling to formulate
the best response to his rebuttal I
would reply I would really appreciate
your thoughts on this objection again
thanks to all you do so your professor
is postulating in eternal you
the first thing I would say is that the
Big Bang seems to rule that out there
was definitely a beginning of all we see
now I think almost I think most
scientists would concede that point I
suppose you could argue for an infinite
eternal string of big bangs where like
it explodes expands contracts explodes
again you know back and forth like an
accordion universe type of thing or
maybe more plausibly you could say that
a multiverse right where we are just one
bubble universe on this infinite cluster
of other universes all right but what
about the idea because here's the thing
even in a multiverse scenario that
doesn't of itself get around God because
then who created the multiverse maybe we
do live in a multiverse who knows right
and even I don't even and I'm sure there
are ways to understand this that I just
can't but the universe is so vast
already that how would you even
distinguish from one universe from
another like it might as well be a
million universes
considering how incomprehensible ìbig it
is but you know if maybe it's a
multiverse where do the multiverse come
come from then you say well there are
infinite universes all right well I
would say that that seems illogical for
this reason and this is how I think
William Lane Craig and others would
argue it if we're in the midst of if we
are in the midst of an infinite eternal
chain of causes then that means that
there have been an infinite number of
past events leading up to this event
right now so this moment was before this
moment came an infinite number of
moments but if there's an
infinite number of past events before
you get to right now then you would
never get to right now because you would
have to traverse infinity to get to our
spot in the time line which you can't do
because it's infinity so there seems to
be a logical problem with an infinite
chain of events for that reason if
there's an infinite if we have an
infinite past then we never should have
arrived at now because it's infinite and
so it that would seem to be logically
impossible not just inconceivable like
your professor says it is inconceivable
but it's inconceivable there are some
inconceivable things that are not
illogical the scale of the universe is
inconceivable but it's not illogical
there's nothing illogical about a very
big thing but I would say that this is
inconceivable because it is illogical
because it is logically impossible to
have an infinite number of past events
all right this is from Jeremy says hi
Matt big fan of the show been listening
to you since you were with the blaze my
question is I'm Jewish and of course I
appreciate to no end
the Christian support for Israel and the
Jewish people as a whole but my question
is why is it there in the first place if
we're a false religion if Christians
thought differently they'd be Jewish
then what makes us different in the eyes
of Christians then say Buddhists Hindus
take your pick since I'm not an expert
on Christian theology maybe I'm
operating from the wrong premise so
wondering your thoughts thanks for all
you do it again love the show thanks
Jeremy a good question and it's a
question you'll probably get a different
answer from depending on who you ask
depending on which Christian you ask
first of all I would say as to the thing
about Judaism being a false religion
Christians do not or should not cannot
really look at Judaism the same way as
Buddhism or Hinduism or Islam or
whatever else because because obviously
we Jews and Christians share quite a bit
of common ground theologically and
Judaism is the the foundation upon which
Christianity was built Jesus was a Jew
after all so
I believe Christianity is the true
religion right I mean it's I wouldn't be
Christian if I didn't believe that I
wouldn't call Judaism a false religion
now I certainly don't
I'm not a Universalist type of person
saying that all religions are true
obviously that can't be the case only
one there are only three options here
right that's one religion is true I
guess is two options I should say one of
the religions is true or none of them
are true I mean those are the options
there in fact there is not that third
option of them all being true so I
believe Christianity is the true
religion that's why I'm Christian but I
wouldn't call Judaism a false religion I
don't really I don't I don't think any
of its any of its basic theological
tenants or false so that's why I don't
think a Christian could call Judaism a
false religion when we share you know
the Old Testament and and the you know
the basic concept of God and everything
from my perspective as a Christian I
suppose I would call it perhaps
incomplete missing the next part of the
puzzle just as you as a Jew given that
you're Jewish and a Christian I assume
would say that Christians well you
couldn't say that we're completely wrong
about everything right because then you
would be discounting the Old Testament
which we share so instead I guess you
would say that we you know what we've
added to it or something
from your perspective so again there's
common ground there a shared history and
so on which makes that relationship get
much different then the relationship
that a Christian would have with
something like Hinduism which is just a
completely different thing and there's
no shared ground there at all
as for Israel well I'll tell you why I
support Israel it's it's our most
important ally in the region and it's a
country which shares our values to a
large extent and that's the basis of my
support and it's a strong basis that's
that's why I support Israel and of
course yes I respect the religious
history of the country as well and I
admire that I think that's wonderful now
there are Christians who seem to think
that somehow the fate of the world is
still tied to the actual physical plot
of land there in Israel and so they have
theological reasons for their support as
well which I'm which I guess you've
picked up on now I think that that's a
miss reading personally I I don't think
Christian teaching supports the idea
that salvation is at all tied to
geographic locations anymore but I do
think that there's some of that mixed up
in the in this support for Israel among
Christians but as I said there's no need
to get into the the theology of it
because even without it in my mind
there's good solid strategic reason to
support our ally in the region and so I
I guess Christians who support Israel
it's gonna be one of those two reasons
maybe both alright this is from tea just
tea I don't know if it's mr. tea or just
just the letter T there's all I'm given
says hi Matt your statements about the
Bible disturbed me greatly you think
people can be convinced with logic and
science logic and science and scare
quotes there by the way logic and
science you know you know it's you know
it's not good when someone puts science
in quotes or especially when they put
logic in quotes you think you can be
people that people can be convinced with
logic and science but do you deny that
the Bible is the basis for all logic and
science when you look outside of the
Bible for truth you find nonsense you
cannot convince someone of truth without
the Bible and even if you do you have
only made it so that they are mistaken
in a different way than they were before
okay do i do i deny that the bible is
the basis for logic and science yes I do
because that makes no sense now by the
Bible is the basis for science i and for
logic I I don't even know what you mean
now I'm not saying okay be very clear
but what I'm saying here because I know
I'm gonna get strawman to death on this
one I'm not saying that the Bible is
incompatible with logic and science I'm
not saying
bible is illogical or anti-science i
don't think that and I believe that God
is the basis for source of logic and
science God is yes and it's true that
you cannot have logic or science without
God God as the as the the base of all
being of all truth but the Bible is not
God the Bible itself the actual book
like the book that I've got several of
them on the Shelf back there are those
books back there they are not God I
don't have God on the Shelf I have a
book on the shelf right now God gave us
a book and the book is of prime
importance but to call it the basis for
logic and science is just a meaningless
assertion the Bible is not meant to be
that that's not what it's supposed the
God didn't give us the Bible is a
science textbook and that's okay
and it's also not a logic 101 course
either for logic which again derives
from God the source of all truth but for
logic you know what God gave us for
logic he gave us our minds and we're
allowed to use our minds and we do use
our minds to logically sort through
problems every day without consulting
the Bible if you want to cross the
street okay what are you gonna do you're
gonna look both ways right why do you
look both ways well that you are
logically problem-solving you're saying
to yourself well I want to get across
this street I don't want to get hit by a
truck how do I do it oh I know I'll look
this way look that way that is a you
have just lodged that's logical
problem-solving right there that is
problem-solving okay do you consult the
Bible I mean but before you cross street
do you pull out the Bible and say let me
see let's see so says here in John
chapter 3 no no you don't do that you
just you just use your head and you use
your mind that God gave you and you
cross the street if if the Bible didn't
exist would you not be able to figure
out how to cross the street or tie your
shoe or solve a math problem do
arithmetic I mean that's logic
well let's hope so because the Bible in
its current form as a book you know the
Bible that we have right now that the
actual book with everything compiled all
all the all the all the little books
inside the big book that actual thing
did not exist for thousands of years of
human history and people still engaged
in logic the ancient Greeks
okay the ancient Greeks had no Bible
they had no they had they had no
Christian faith they had lots of logic
are you gonna tell me that the ancient
Greeks were not logical hey do you
really want to go out on that limb so
what Aristotle was not logical Tummie
Aristotle was an illogical person so
that assertion again is is meaningless
and the Bible is the source of science I
mean come on again God is the source of
science and the Bible is compatible with
it but you don't look to the Bible to
make scientific discoveries I'm sorry
but scientists don't do that they don't
they don't look at the Bible and then
make scientific discoveries they really
don't we didn't discover germs in the
Bible or gravity or heliocentrism or the
spherical earth or the polio vaccine or
human flight or the theory of relativity
or black holes or I mean literally
millions of other scientific discoveries
does that mean that the Bible
contradicts those things no but to say
that the Bible is the source of them is
just a statement without meaning we
discovered germs in a laboratory not in
Scripture the Bible really is not used
and has never been used as a as a
reference point for science because
that's not the point of the Bible that's
not why God gave us the Bible that's not
its function God gave us other things
for that God gave us science he gave us
brains he gave us minds
he gave us an orderly universe that we
can look at and understand and discover
things about and run experiments on he
gave us other tools and those tools are
good too those tools are from God the
Bible is not the only tool that we were
given we were given other tools and
we're allowed to use them we're allowed
to think that's okay we're allowed to
use our brains someone told me on
Twitter yesterday and I'm in the
this I'm not exaggerating this is really
a direct quote from this person he said
you can see that you can see it on my
Twitter if you go this person said
everything God wants us to know is in
the Bible the Bible contains everything
God wants us to know now if I had read
that tweet a few weeks ago before I
started this whole long argument over
this issue if I'd read that tweet a few
weeks ago I would assume that that
person doesn't really mean that you know
the hyperbole he doesn't really mean it
like that
but now I see that he probably did mean
that because there are apparently a lot
of people who literally think that they
think that the whole summation of human
knowledge is in the Bible and we don't
need to know anything outside of it but
by that logic God didn't want us to know
that the Earth orbits the Sun or that
viruses cause sickness and he didn't
want us to know how to do open-heart
surgery and he didn't want us to know
about penicillin or electricity or
Tylenol and so on and so on and so on
and so on
you see this kind of stuff it really
makes Christians look like sheltered
anti-science illogical cultists who
believe that the sum total of human
knowledge is contained in a book
compiled 16 or 17th centuries ago and
that is just not true and you don't have
to think that and you don't think that
because there are so many things that
you believe I mean you believe in
electricity I don't you do I mean you
you you know the electricity exists it's
a thing I've got lights on right now you
turn your light on well that's not in
the Bible it's really not there was not
a how-to on how to discover electricity
in the Bible it's not incompatible but
it wasn't in there because it wasn't
meant to be it's it's it was not now
look if just think about this for a
second because you really set yourself
up I mean you make the Bible look bad
and you and you set yourself up for
failure for failure more importantly you
set
the Christian case up to fail when you
pretend that the Bible is some sort of
science reference book because if God
really wanted to put all scientific
knowledge in a book well then when you
open the Bible there should be a lot of
stuff in there that isn't in there I
mean there's a God who knows all has all
the scientific knowledge in the world if
you're pretending that that's what the
Bible is supposed to be well then
someone is going to open up that book
expecting to find what they do not find
I mean they're gonna expect to find just
one after another of just sigh just all
of these scientific truths and
discoveries written in that book way
before they were ever discovered by man
but that's not what you find because
that's not what the book is supposed to
be and that's okay alright um let's see
one more
oh yeah well I've definitely got a well
I I need 20 minutes for this but I don't
have 20 minutes this is from Kyle says
please rank the following Nicktoons Doug
Rugrats read and Stimpy are real
monsters hey arnold the angry beavers
Rocko's Modern Life yeah I was I was up
tossing and turning all that us all this
email last night I was I was trying to
work through this I had a chalkboard up
you know and I was I was doing I was
connecting the dots and I had strings
connecting the different I was like
trying to work it all out here's what
I'll say I've got to give the top spot
to Doug I think Doug funnie was the
voice of his generation so I got to give
it to Doug was you know that was heart
and soul and in comedy I mean hilarious
comedy in Doug so I'll get I'll get Doug
number one you got to go Rugrats number
two I mean you could make it an argument
for Rugrats number one but I also think
that you know Rugrats was like when I
got to be about seven or eight years old
I'd grown out of Rugrats you know I mean
I had graduated to Doug at that point so
but I'll go Rugrats number two the
I'll throw red & stimpy in there even
though I wasn't really allowed to watch
that when I was a kid my parents thought
it was satanic which you know it kind of
was in a way it does sort of seem that
way so ren and stimpy satanic number 3
I'm sorry I didn't I didn't dock it too
much for the fact of being satanic and
then I'll put I guess I'll go rock was
Modern Life Oh real monsters Hey Arnold
and then the angry beavers I mean angry
beavers and our monsters those are kind
of like minor Nicktoons so obviously
those will be the bottom two that's how
I would that's how I would work it out
and that is the definitive ranking from
here on out and of course when I am
theocratic fascist dictator of the world
everyone will be required to memorize
and affirm those rankings upon penalty
of death thanks for watching everybody
thanks for listening have a great
weekend
Godspeed today on the Ben Shapiro show
Ilhan Omar's defenders castigates speech
as incitement Michael Knowles is
attacked at a speech and we checked the
mailbag that's today on the Ben Shapiro
show